hey guys so what causes dandruff and how
can we get rid of it well that's what
we're gonna talk about in this video so
let's get to it
[Music]
hey just very quick if it's your first
time here on my channel i'm daniel and
welcome to d LM model lifestyle
subscribe and also click that
notification belt so you won't miss any
of the next videos now dandruff sucks
and it can be very very embarrassing but
it's actually more common than you think
it is because one out of every five
people out there dandruff why so many
because the way people try and treat
dandruff actually comes from myths and
you can make things a lot worse so let
me quickly tell you the real causes of
dandruff and how you can treat it
now irritated an oily skin causes
dandruff not dry skin that's a myth
now if your scalp is red and greasy and
covered with white flakes then you
probably have seborrheic dermatitis
which is a severe form of dandruff and
this can cause similar problems on other
areas of your body especially where you
have more oil glands another cause is
yeast and fungus growth now most adults
have a common fungus that is called
malassezia I hope that's how you
pronounce it but it lives in our skull
yeah it sounds a little bit scary and
look but it's true so this fungus can
basically irritate your skull causing it
to disturb the Scopes cell growth and
then your cells get replaced too fast
and it causes too many dead skin cells
which then just mix it with the oil on
your scalp and then you get dandruff now
some guys with a oily scalp can also
have a yeast problem called petit rose
poram or BIA Claire I hope that's how
you pronounce it but it basically feeds
on the skin oils and it causes dandruff
you're not washing your hair enough yes
I know what you're thinking
and it's true washing your hair too much
is stripping it from its natural oil and
that's not good that's true but on the
opposite side if you don't wash it
enough it is also very bad for your hair
especially if you use a lot of hair
products leaving it in there is not good
so if everything in life you need a good
balance so how do you get rid of it well
first you got to use a good anti
dandruff shampoo like Nizoral
and i'll also add a few other options
for you in the video description that
you can check out and then all you got
to do is wash your hair three to four
times every week with shampoo and then
two to three times with conditioner
every week and that should do the trick
if it doesn't then you should contact a
dermatologist because you might have a
more serious problem now if you have any
problems with hair loss then check out
one of these videos I'm sure you might
like them if you like this video give it
a thumbs up subscribe and we will talk
soon bye
[Music]